avions trop tôt et plateau du petit
déjeuner un peu sec mais tant pis
direction zurich à la recherche de queen
queen vieux routier du rock'n'roll qui
produit depuis plus d'une dizaine
d'années un rock efficace qui déplace
encore et toujours des dizaines de
milliers de fanatiques john deacon
guitare basse
roger taylor batterie brian may
guitariste et surtout le chanteur
freddie mercury nous accorde une
entrevue exclusive qui commence par
votre accent français est merveilleux ça
commence bien
c'est un spectacle complètement nouveau
dont nous ne sommes qu'à la troisième
représentation
mais à paris je suis sûr que tout sera
fin prêt dans nos chansons il ya
beaucoup de sexe mais personnellement je
ne vais pas chercher l'inspiration en
eau de montagne un boulot pour moi c'est
comme un job 9 à 5
en fait tout le monde écrit dans le
groupe et ceci n'est valable que pour
moi c'est pour ça que nous sommes
incapables de faire un disque vraiment
homogène
il ya beaucoup de fans que nous
n'aurions jamais cru pouvoir faire à
bord a été dans le business pendant plus
de dix ans elle est très difficile de le
savoir ce que l'on va faire juste après
il est très très important pour nous
d'aller dans des pays que nous avons
jamais fait de concert comme la russie
ou la chine
c'est aussi bien de revenir dans les
pays où on a l'habitude mais il faut
s'ouvrir de nouveaux horizons
nous avons été récemment en amérique du
sud c'était fantastique de voir à quel
point les gens voulaient du rock ne
pouvait pas savoir on pouvait pas le
savoir avant d'y aller
pendant plus de deux heures quinn a
déversé ses dizaines de milliers droite
sans lesquels le rock and roll ne serait
pas ce qu'il est il a aussi surpris les
12000 spectateurs de zurich avec des
éclairages impressionnant alors comme
les six camions de 30 tonnes de matériel
sont au rendez-vous du palais des sports
à paris ce soir
il est temps d'atterrir
à ma façon